[Music]
okay pause if your stomach just turned
watching that even though you're on the
couch like me there's a scientific
reason for that it's called vicarious
experience and it's basically when you
feel somebody else's happiness pain or
anxiety let's zoom into the science and
figure out why this phenomenon is so
critical for our evolution as humans and
as a society
when you experience something
frightening or scary like jumping out of
a plane watching a family member scream
in terror
whether it's a prank or not our fingers
may start to sweat our heart may begin
to race this is our bodies fight or
flight
that's bianca jones marlin a
neuroscientist at columbia university
she says the fight-or-flight response is
our brain's way of keeping us safe
biology wants us to survive our brain
wants us to survive so it turns out just
watching a scary situation will signal
to your brain to elicit a fear response
that's because your brain sends an alert
that the situation could cause serious
hurt or worse and we learn to adapt
accordingly if we see someone leaning
over and they go too far and it doesn't
end well we have now learned from that
situation without having to do it
ourselves
our brain is constantly taking in
information for our survival this
reaction lowers our chance of death and
ups our chances for success it's a
win-win in all kinds of brains mice
primates seals humans have the ability
to learn from observing but how does the
brain learn from the experiences of
others and which of its many parts are
involved to get answers i called aza
also a psychiatrist and neuroscientist
at yale who specializes in social
learning the hippocampus is really
important for social memory and social
memory which is critical for social
learning kicks in when we're little when
we're watching our parents or other
people around us here's a brain and this
seahorse-shaped hippocampus is connected
to two other brain areas that are
critical for vicarious or social
learning there's the amygdala which you
probably know as the brain sphere center
and then there's the anterior cingulate
cortex or acc our new brain friend
that's important for decision making and
social interactions the acc and the
amygdala are intricately connected and
those connections are important for
encoding social aspects of learning in
aca's mouse experiments for example it
was learning that a light turning on
signaled an impending electric shock
whether the mice experienced the shock
directly or whether they were just
watching both groups ended up learning
that the light was bad news when aza
looked closer at what was going on he
found that neurons in the acc whose
activity is important for social
learning changed their firing patterns
and that signaled to the amygdala that
something bad was coming and miguel
learns that and then knows this is
something that should have you know a
negative fair output and other research
groups have found similar results in
humans when you're watching people
attempt death-defying feats you're not
going into a death spiral emotionally
but your brain is taking note telling
you you're safe for now but if you try
that you might not be so why is social
learning important the brain craves
social interaction from the time we're
little and those early social
interactions hone our social skills this
teaches us to learn from others
experiences which can help us avoid
potentially dangerous situations
but it's not just about avoidance
congratulations
social learning also helps establish
community through empathy think of when
your little sister finally makes the
shot
or when the ending of the titanic movie
comes on and you feel like you're living
the loss all over again
commiserating with others even in bad
times helps us feel better except our
ability to relate to other people may
not be the same across the board that's
because the brain is constantly making
predictions about what comes next and
those predictions are based on past
experience which brings us back to some
interesting findings from aza's work in
mice he found that experiencing the
shock directly well that's actually not
necessary for them to learn but they
just learn much better when they
experience it which sort of makes sense
even intuitively from human experience
you can kind of more relate when you
experience the thing that the person is
talking about it's the brain's
equivalent of walking in somebody else's
shoes the more conscious we become about
how our brains are conditioned how that
drives our behavior and actually
understand
how the various inputs that we get
during development shape that i think we
can actually then begin to consciously
evolve the brain in in a pro-empathic
way which i actually think is critical
for our survival as a species aza said
that finding common ground that cuts
past our tribal tensions is really
critical we also have other tools at our
disposal like therapy music and
psychedelics the last two have been used
by indigenous communities for centuries
to promote social bonding and empathy so
next time you watch a horror movie or
listen to a sad song and you start
screaming or crying don't be embarrassed
know it's your brain behaving the way
it's supposed to based on thousands of
years of evolution if you want to know
more about brains leave me your
questions below and don't forget to hit
subscribe thanks for watching